i feel really bad for guys who's
thingamajigging oh yeah oh
so you know h3h3 one of the that's ethan
right ethan what's his wife's name ela
we're gonna make a whole video going
through all the beef um between h3 and
andrew tate but this is this is just a
piece of it okay let's go yeah it's
pretty sad because ethan really did used
to be so funny and he's just he's turned
into such a big baby you know going
against everything that he used to stand
for it's i mean fame is hard fame messes
with people's heads and i mean
guys if i ever cower to the matrix i
have a i have a worm in my brain and
it's not me if i ever coward in the
matrix i need i need a biff upside the
head and i'm happy to take it i need a
biff
i'm not kidding i'm happy to take it i
you know what sometimes and so we got to
keep each other in check yeah for real
real quick before we get into the video
make sure to follow us on rumble
instagram and all of our social medias
we'll pop them up right here youtube has
been taking down some of our videos so
just in case we get d platform i want to
make sure you guys have us on
decentralized platforms what's his name
what's his name you know that guy
you know that guy the the the overweight
one
the oh oh
ethan klein now i discovered something
about ethan klein i was corrected so i
briefly
was talking about ethan klein on sneako
show which is coming soon to rumble by
the way
and um
i said yeah you know ethan's chance to
ever live a life like mine is is well
passed because he's what 12 15 years
older than me and i said that on
chalantly just looking at pictures of
him and guessing his age do you know how
old ethan cline is andrew
do you know do you want me to tell you
43 44 what year were you born in
1986
he was born in 1985 you're the same
[ __ ] age as this guy this guy's your
age
two and a bit years older than me i
don't wanna be i don't wanna be called
off being unfactual you actually like
serious uh no i'm a hundred percent
serious everyone look up ethan klein's
age his year of birth is 1985 he's
andrew's age he is andrew's age yeah
wow
wow that's bad so i want everyone to
take these things into account
when we discuss the information that's
been sent to us on ethan cline do you
think klein is my age the information
that's been sent to us that we can say
by the way
so
yeah this picture of tate just kills me
every time it's so funny all right find
it and then pause on it look at this gun
drawer oh i like that isn't that cool
he's got you know what he's got to see
toms oh yeah we have a navy seal friend
who um has a cool oh my god it's like a
hidden room and really say all this i
don't know he has a lot of guns he's his
his gun his gun and weapon collection
all legal all on the up and up all
registered unreal like if [ __ ] goes down
in this country we'll go to his house
yeah we've done actually a lot of work
with navy seals previously so if you
want to see us do some podcasts actually
we're going to get him on a podcast
because he actually we should make him
we should give him a university class
because he is would he do that brilliant
we could do we're going to talk we got
to
talk
quick shout out to the get [ __ ] done
university this is like my full focus
right now it is [ __ ] nuts i actually
have some really brilliant people in my
circle that i could get to do a chapter
of each unit each
you know chapter by chapter so yeah it's
all of my social media marketing
knowledge business tips health you know
day-to-day stuff i also have other
experts making their own fields and
we're bringing on non-stop cool people
and for the first 1 000 people that sign
up you get in for 30 a month bro 30
that's like a sandwich nowadays 30
so that's like four or five days of
coffee yeah and it's a lot into that i
chose the monthly subscription route to
show you
or you could pay five thousand dollars a
month for college yeah i don't i don't
want to make this plug too long but i'm
just saying like this like it's 30 a
month like that that is not bad at all
for the amount of information i'm
providing and it's only for the first
thousand people and then the price goes
up a lot so stay tuned and join the
discord let's get back to this you know
so here no pause pause just pause so
listen this is clearly an unfair shitty
picture of ethan and ethan truly i'm
going to be fair he doesn't have a lot
of wrinkles and part of that is because
he's got a little extra poundage and
that smooths them which is he looks
pretty though she is pretty and there
was a time that was it tristan or tate
that said she wasn't pretty she is
pretty oh yeah he was roasting her he
was roasting her she has beautiful eyes
she has a beautiful mouth i mean
you know she she's a very pretty girl i
think but you know whatever maybe i'm
being kind ethan
wouldn't look as old as he does he does
look early 40s and he just needs to i
just get in shape a little he just needs
to get in shape i think he looks his age
just fat i think he just looks like a
mid-30s fat guy
no he does look older than 35. maybe
that's an old picture too i don't know
some people great early and that's
what's happening here but if he but gray
on men looks good like women like that
believe it or not being ethan klein is
like a worst nightmare
yeah i know you're you're fat
you're depressed you're in your mid-30s
but he's my age how is he so he looks so
terrible i didn't know this i i
mentioned 87 35 the same at the same age
35 yeah
bro fights how the [ __ ] does he look
this bad he must have tried
he must have tried
that's a crazy thought that he's like
i've been through 90 like people trying
to kill me and how do i look better than
you what have you done you're so badass
the crazy thing is that you got to stay
the same distance and i'm not trying to
make it make it i'm not trying to be an
[ __ ] but it just comes off this way
sometimes it really is relatively easy
to take care of yourself just choose
different foods go for a nice long walk
climb the stairs instead of taking the
elevator it's not that hard you don't
everybody doesn't have to look like tate
and tristan like ramped in muscles and
six packs but you can you can really
take care of yourself and keep your
youth and keep your health and be strong
and and have energy every day it's
really you it's not doing some push-ups
throughout the day that's all i really
do because i i've been working a lot
we've been moving i've been in the
kitchen talking to grandma right what am
i doing i'm doing push-ups against the
kitchen counter lady push-ups because i
don't just i know i know some girls do
the real push-ups i don't i don't i
don't need to i have nothing to prove he
asked me to do a push-up one day i was
like i can't i've never done a push-up
in my life but i do the ones leaning
against the kitchen counter you can't do
one like one one real push-up i can't if
you want to make it like a life goal for
me to do one solid push-up i will do it
i but you're gonna have to help me
through that that's how bad it is i've
never done a push-up high school
elementary school high school college
they like do a push-up and everything i
can't at least here at least you're my
mother you can be pretty little skinny
spaghetti arms i know you tried to hit
me earlier and i was like
and i look better than this man it's a
[ __ ] he looks awful wait let me let
me put him up again let me mr producer
him again
because he looks so terrible let me see
if i can mr producer
it's not great because you can't receive
from power
you can't really see it but you get the
point
uh what like this
yeah there we go you see me i sit here
yeah like but what the [ __ ] he's playing
bad he's joking he's really bad
i know they sent us everything on ethan
haven't they oh they've sent us
everything literally everything
guys close your eyes close your eyes you
don't want to see this
i told you to close your eyes you should
have done it your age how the [ __ ] is he
my get that off my screen what a piece
what a [ __ ] bro i know
i don't know
oh oh he's the same age as you so i just
wanted to put that out there
before we start going into the things
that have food on the face i skied
people with food on the face that's not
cute ethan somebody this is my video i
think no i don't care i don't care food
on the face is disgusting sometimes but
i gotta say they do for context so just
so everybody knows we're here we are
we're making fun of ethan for for sure
what is [ __ ] but you from when you
were the tiniest from when you knew you
understood like a year year and a half
sunny used to walk around mooning
everybody he moons everybody that's life
it's not lies i gotta find pictures
because i'm sure we have so many
pictures of you you're gonna last
hanging out i mean it's 35 so who can
explain that to a five-year-old
but
a one two three sixteen year old yeah
this kid's walking around with his ass
hanging out his whole life it's funny
and sold our youtube counselor so we're
here with more live viewers and more
subs than we had on youtube anyway so
you can't cancel us you can't cancel you
yeah so you're right so ethan's been on
a mission to try and cancel us and
what's happened is there's some very uh
astute investigators who've been digging
into ethan's life
emailing me hey i got dirt on ethan and
i'm like i don't really give a [ __ ] i
don't he talks about me i don't really
have to do reply videos i don't care but
they've sent us so much stuff and then
it's just yeah it's kind of good isn't
it yeah it it it's kind of funny i mean
it's just when you take into account
that he's our age
that he fights for censorship
um it just makes these things very very
funny like you said this is a chance to
show that the people that you listen to
and the people that you watch for
entertainment are hypocrites and they
are liars and they are mouthpieces for
the machine where do you want to start
do you want to start with him wow i got
this one i got this one i'm talking
about is how his dick doesn't work oh
this is not no oh
medicated for that [ __ ] 20 milligrams
for every [ __ ] day
he said my dick feels like a piece of
wood
the side effect and i'm fat by the way
also
you heard that right you guys and i'm
fat by the way
also a side effect it's just sad the way
he talks about himself like that like
it's just oh i'm just fat nothing on the
one hand i appreciate the honesty
because i think that there are people
that need to hear like you're not alone
in that yeah but he's not like doing
anything about it but but then there's
right the other hand is yeah it's like
yeah i'm fat but i'm working towards it
i'm doing stuff to improve myself that's
like a good message to have and it's
motivational i feel really bad for guys
who's thingamajiggy oh yeah i don't know
i mean that's rough stuff why i don't
know it's just weird i mean i guess you
gotta get into personal experiences but
like i'm just saying it's it's
i can imagine it's a real emotional
screw-up because that's one of the
things that like if you got nothing else
you got that you know i got those pills
for it now yeah okay no pills so this
video is quite old he would have been
about my age when he said this now what
i really like is yeah you know my penis
doesn't work i have no sensation in my
penis it's the antidepressants that are
doing this they're also making me fat
big sip from a can of soda
yes the antidepressants made they're
high in calorie are they or like like
seriously now but that explains a lot
about him you have to understand a man
whose penis does not work
is the type of man to talk badly about
men like me and you when the other fat
guy who we are going to get to was
complaining that women don't like him
and women don't go home with him let me
tell you something ethan klein and daz
black
you have to understand that not only are
we nice not only are we charming not
only do women like our company in every
single way plus we're not fat sacks of
[ __ ] if you have any respect for women
and their freedom of sexual choice which
i genuinely do you have to understand
that women choosing a man after a night
out to go home with they want to enjoy
the sexual experience people want me to
play again because they said about the
sound you're right you're right but you
that's a really they want to enjoy the
sexual experience listen to him again
talk about how his dick doesn't work
i have depression i'm medicated for that
[ __ ] 20 milligrams lux for every [ __ ]
day
my dick feels like a piece of wood
like i have no sensation in my penis
a side effect and i'm fat by the way
also a side effect i have depression
he's drinking lacroix he's not drinking
seltzer his fatness is not because of
the medication the medication will give
you 10 or 15 but if he wanted he could
turn that into muscle if he still is
feeling like he doesn't want to exercise
the lexapro is not working you got to
call your doctor and either get off of
it or change it oh because that's what
it's supposed to do it's supposed to
make you not depressed supposed to make
you like want to do [ __ ] and be alive
look i'm not depressed and i don't take
the medicine so i don't know but does it
just like mask it so it's like i'm okay
with this or is it supposed to like make
you want to do and like start um like
make habits that you know make you not
depressed like does it just mask it or
does it make you do stuff that
ultimately makes you not depressed you
know what i'm saying i think both so all
right here's here's where it gets real
youtube and rumble uh i'm on
antidepressants because when i'm off of
them i just walk around crying like for
no reason like my life could be perfect
everything can be money and roses and
laughter and best friends and
everything's great and i just walk
around crying like what the [ __ ] is this
about and i call the doctor i'm like
stop the crying i don't know what it is
i don't know what i'm not a scientist i
don't give a [ __ ] just make it stop and
for me um the one that i'm on does not
cause weight gain it doesn't cause
numbness i it actually just takes away
mental numbness it doesn't cause do i
feel meant do i no that's really nice
that's why it's like my stance on
antidepressants is kind of weird because
you're on them and you're still really
articulate smart and have a full
personality but i know a lot of people
feel like they're just like watching
their life behind a movie screen with
like fog in front of it i think that but
i'm also so the antidepressants iman
also help manage anxiety i have like one
anxiety attack a year what that's my
norm i think people that have regular
daily anxiety attacks they're on
different medications that do make you
numb that just that zone you out i i i
don't know i don't take any of that [ __ ]
that's like kawanapin people are taking
and it just makes you high and not do
you want to say what you think or you
don't want to i'm not judging that um
isa talipram i don't know which is
which is
a generic for i think it's alexa we'll
look it up and we'll put it on the
screen um i'll i'll let you know uh
because i'm not sure off the top of my
head because i've been taking it so long
i don't even remember but you know
listening to tate talk about depression
i'm like i really want to be off of it
but i also know when i have been off of
it i literally walk around crying for no
reason and i know that there's a logical
part of my brain going you have no
reason for this [ __ ] what are you doing
so that's where my argument of
depression is real comes from um i don't
know if it's different for women but i
don't think so
just because men go through this i think
part of it is genetic uh my father
suffered from depression but he had ptsd
um and that side of the family generally
had some depressive problems uh where my
mother's side of the family no
depression another person that is
[ __ ] nuts they're just [ __ ] nuts
this is just a lot of anger and
a lot of a lot of uh gumption on that
side of the family so i i do feel for
ethan what my point is that said even
though i have this thing i try to keep
the dope i personally fight to keep the
dosage as low as possible because you
know i i don't want to be dependent on
that so you have to get out there as
soon as it starts to work even a little
bit you got to exercise you got to hang
out with the people that bring you up
you got to get the fresh air you got to
eat healthy you got to lay off the soda
and the sugar and the garbage and the
alcohol i know i'm always drinking here
but this is the only time i really drink
we have a glass of wine when we film
that's about it yeah i know everyone's
like mom's an alcoholic in the comments
and like she's an alcoholic you would
have way worse skin at this point at
this point your skin would look like
kakaju i'd look like ethan no i'm sorry
i was just kidding i was just kidding
nathan ethan you got a very pretty wife
i don't care what tristan says okay
let's go yeah but i was literally gonna
say like you you do all those other
things that you should be doing to not
be depressed um already and a lot of the
people that just take it the anti like
the thing that tate says is the people
that take the antidepressants don't do
those other things they eat junk they
don't go to the gym they're fat but you
do those things and you can tell that
there's something off so you take a
minimal dose of something to reduce that
to just kind of just kind of finish it
up but because before i took the
vacation
i literally would exercise meditation
prayer healthy nutrition walking the dog
spending time with positive people i was
doing all the things and it still wasn't
working so the small dose for me
personally it's not for everybody did
they did the thing but you're right i
did and i still now that i have that i
still do all those other things because
i don't want to have to be totally
dependent on those things i want to take
as much control of my life and my health
as i can and everybody should yeah i
feel you right you got heartburn stop
eating [ __ ] cheese fries for
breakfast i mean it's that simple who do
you know that's eating cheese flowers
for breakfast all right let's keep going
i have to understand the fact that let's
pretend
in your
universe that that your reality is true
tristan's growing on me you didn't like
tristan i didn't know i didn't dislike
trip oh you said andrew was more
interesting i didn't dislike tristan i
just thought tristan was like yeah you
know you know what he's really growing
on oh i like no i like tristan a lot
well you've had more interest in
exposure yeah there's really growing on
me i got to say tristan i have to say
since being in the war room it's been a
great experience so far 24 hours super
welcome yeah everyone's been super
welcoming we haven't had time to talk
about it yeah okay we'll talk about it
later that women will always go home
with a guy who's ugly who's uh an ugly
person on the inside who's rude who's
mean who's cruel but they don't choose
you because you're fat and overweight
that who cares
who cares
the sexual experience they will get from
going home with you is nothing it's zero
i mean
i've got friends who actually who are
sexual experts and you know talk about
this stuff it's not really my
uh it's not something i preach about on
my platform but the basis of sexual
performance is
not collapsing and sweating and dying
after two minutes of light cardio that's
just the basis of it so if you actually
have any respect for women and think
their sexual choices are down to them
and they can decide who they have sex
with and they have sexual freedom which
i think too
you can't get mad that they don't go
home with you it's like being a car
salesman selling broken down ugly ass
cars with no engine that won't move
saying working from point ferraris you
are
stupid literally intellectually stupid
if you don't understand why women don't
want to sleep with you and do you think
daz black
as is gonna be a good sexual performer
do you believe he's going to give a
woman the because it's a big decision
for a woman they're letting someone
inside of their body they're being
intimate with somebody who perhaps they
don't know very well when they decide to
go home with somebody that's a big
decision do you think that they want
yeah i'm not getting into the into this
too much because i'm on a thing video
with my son but does black doesn't look
like a good time seconds a very very
light tickling sensation followed by you
collapsing and crying for their
investment of upping their body count
they don't and that's what you people
need to understand this is why women
don't choose you on the base level this
is base level [ __ ] i'm surprised these
guys don't get it wait wait wait the guy
who's trying to say i'm a bad person all
day every day and trying to insult me
his dick doesn't work and yeah his dick
doesn't work he's my age yeah he's your
age
he's on antidepressants yeah very too
young for that and his dick doesn't work
and he's grossly overweight even with a
dick that worked i mean how long is that
guy going for you know the thing about
the antidepressant thing please tell me
it's it's interesting to me
if you
no nobody super chat
same ethan klein who said women should
be conquered
conquered with what yeah exactly people
should know when they're conquered yeah
but
what's amazing to me is this
if you need pills if you need
antidepressants to live your life
because your worldview has managed to
construct a life which is so miserable
and depressing that you need pills to
even keep yourself functioning
why do you think anybody is going to
respect your opinion on the world
because nobody wants to think like you
because if they thought like you they'd
end up like you
you don't really so this isn't this is
really interesting from what he's from
what we the con
an interesting segue from the
conversation we just had you know like i
want to be clear that the things that
happened to me just happen and the
logical part of my brain is going this
doesn't make sense you're this is
[ __ ] and it's very hard to explain
to somebody that hasn't gone through it
like why am i crying my life is perfect
he maybe by the grace of god these
gentlemen haven't gone through that so i
it bothers me that i'm on this
medication for the same reasons that
tate is saying but i also don't think
that it invalidates my
uh world view yeah but it's he's saying
like the way the way it is with men it's
like if you look up to someone and you
like idolize them then you look at like
the way they think as you like look up
to the way they think and the way they
do so why would you look up to ethan if
the way he thinks is being on medic
pills and
what
you're not wrong you're not wrong i
think if ethan said
yeah i take this medication because
there's something going on that i can't
handle or that i don't understand or
i've tried to i've tried to wrangle and
i can't but now that i take it it took
the edge off and i'm [ __ ] awesome you
got you know that would be one thing but
now you've got ethan saying i take these
pills and i'm still sad and fat
like my thing doesn't work like i get
tate's point on that but i don't i i've
said it before and i'll say it again i
don't think that we can completely
invalidate depression and i i am
grateful and this sounds weird i am
almost grateful a little bit that i have
the depression that i have to the low
degree that it can be managed by a
low-level dosage um
because it makes me more compassionate
to other people who have real mental
illness like people who have like
bipolar disorder and schizophrenia
and real [ __ ] or sad are not to be
emulated why would you want to think
like a sad person why would you want to
agree with a person who needs pills to
feed but who's going to respect your
opinion on the world because nobody
wants to think like you because i would
love this would be a great conversation
to have like live because i'd like to
have him be more compassionate to people
like me who are just hey i get the [ __ ]
that happens when and i don't know why
and i can't explain it but this helps
and now i'm a much stronger better
person because of it i understand his
position again on ethan but don't [ __ ]
on everyone but the majority of people
working where it's working be careful
with the majority of people with the
with the big statements what are you
trying to say i'm just gonna say like i
feel like the majority of people just
just take that to take those medicines
just to mask the issue and they don't
they don't do all the other stuff like
you said you did like you tried a
million things and you still do all
those things that are beneficial to you
and should help a normal person get out
of depression a lot of people don't do
that they just go right to taking pills
all right i can't say that for sure but
i can say i agree with you because i see
other people with like i've got diabetes
or i'm fat or my this hurts or that
hurts i've got i've got acid reflux and
they go straight to the doctor to take
pills instead of doing the things
diabetes has been proven to be curable
with diet yeah that's simple but people
have no self-control which takes us back
to tate's whole point of control your
mind control your mouth control yourself
and you will solve all your problems so
you're right i mean i i i so by that
standard you're probably right that most
people turn to pills as a first resort
instead of as a last resort i turned to
them as the last true sorry keep going
you don't respect the thinking of people
who are sad because people who are sad
are not to be emulated why would you
want to think
like a sad person why would you want to
agree with a person who needs pills to
function
the fact he just said i'm gonna edit the
presence that invalidates your entire
worldview friend because i'm not we're
the same age my dick works and i'm not
an idiot see i'm not i don't feel like
i'm invalidated by it i do feel
understand his point about ethan being
invalidated by it because ethan's not
getting any better what are you taking
this [ __ ] for if it's not making you any
better a soul including every single
person who watches your videos not a
single soul if god were to come down and
give them the choice whether they could
be transported into no i just yawned i
just i held it in
my body or yours not a single one would
choose to be you know
one you lose the game of life
i i don't know what to say the dude's
dick doesn't work and he needs pills to
function like this is such easy shooting
fish in a barrel i don't know what to
say but the guy's got two kids you're
gonna outlive him by about 25 years plus
do you have enough respect for your
family and your children to take care of
your health on the most fundamental
basic level i love that i love that
family man i love seeing people like i
love my family i love my wife and kids
more than anything oh my god big mac
yeah
calm down smoking a package take care of
yourself don't tell me how much you love
your kids and then yeah heartbreaking as
andrew said in his in his meeting we all
know that i'm a father you think i am
going to get so overweight that i risk
having a heart attack and dying at age
42 because i like nacho cheese
i like nacho cheese that much that the
time i'm going to spend raising my
family has been severely reduced by risk
of cardiac arrest right you might still
have a heart attack but you don't need
something you don't need to push the
envelope on it i love the way they
simplify stuff like that they're like
you're gonna let [ __ ] nacho cheese
ruin decades with your family it's like
that is like the truth though like
you're really gonna let right down write
down you're gonna like food or
cigarettes or some [ __ ] like that ruin
your life like what like you know how
many people like old people i know that
that died at like 70 because they were
just smoking cigarettes their whole life
like it's just crazy you would grandpa
yeah i would know i would actually know
my grandfather it's kind of sad and he
was the best jesus christ man and
we're the guys who you think are
dangerous
and this is the thing
you have to then question how someone
like ethan becomes someone like ethan
because his his existence is miserable
self-admitted i know
he admits he admits i'm not trying to
insult the guy he admits his his
existence is miserable he admits his
life is unhappy he admits he needs pills
to function
and he admits his penis doesn't work so
nobody wants to be him right right how
do you end up in that terrible position
i will tell you two words ready
his father
his father
now i'm not going to tell anyone his
father's name or address or anything
boxing people is is morally wrong
although we've been doxed a million
times feel free to shop at my house it's
all over the [ __ ] internet
but i do have some of his father's
tweets which his father put out in
public and i've just screenshotted a
twitter account which is completely fine
and completely legal and
i think you should show people this
man's father's twitter interactions
and twitter conversations
sure let's see ethan klein's dad ladies
and gentlemen let's see what we have
here
oh man they really wouldn't want that to
make it fit mr producer
all right so we got this pow
okay
so this is step one met models fan
followed by ethan klein and that's right
okay so his dad follows some internet
model that's no big deal yeah that's no
big deal that's okay i was gonna say
that's your that's the end of the world
ethan klein's twitter account are you
more enthusiastic
gary
sorry that's your dad that's not ethan
that's your dad yeah this is your this
is even client's father
are you more enthusiastic with your blow
jobs there oh disappointing because
you're so hot so this is him on he's
complaining about the only i can't
imagine my my father ever ever saying
this [ __ ] that is just gross
my father was a gentleman i see the
people that like respond to like there's
just there's just like sometimes you're
scrolling on twitter and it's just like
well that's a pair of titties and then
you look in the replies and you're like
like twitter's public like you're
letting like people that follow you see
that you're that down that you're that
damn bad that's insane people were
crying and his son had a following at
this point this is 2017 this is like
peak ethan client oh my god that's nuts
if that's real i mean i'm sure they'll
say disgusting things this bothers me
that a grown all right so if ethan's 35
let's say this guy had him young and
he's 50. that is nuts it's gross my
father would never talk to a woman like
that even if he was alive today and the
internet was blazing that is disgusting
and then they call these people weird if
you saw some of the instant messages
i've been getting on my instagram oh i'm
not i'm never ever sharing them with you
i can't look no they're that bad no
they're they're they're things that like
would make me not ever be able to look
you in the eye again oh disgusting good
no that's horrible horrible yeah i don't
even want to look the way men think it's
okay to just talk to women on the
internet and because young women are so
desperate for attention if you want to
show me the accounts so that if i see
them i can just whip out the glock no
we're just going to leave them alone and
ignore them fans content
of one of his favorite models
okay oh this is getting good what else
do we have here
all right that's that one we've seen
that one
what else do we have here what's this
one
gross that's disturbing oops i've missed
a producer of myself into oblivion
i need to delete this bang
you become ethan klein's father ladies
and gentlemen this is the guy who raised
him i don't know how to delete those
isn't it yeah i'll show you on my phone
uh this one doesn't fit on the screen oh
the comment underneath do you want to
read the comment underneath this
she says thanks to all my fans something
something
it's so good open up the screenshot what
is it
oh you're welcome
praying hands or something let's read it
here it's just something like that
you're welcome yeah yeah you're welcome
so either gary klein replies you're
welcome to this now here's the thing
i understand that pornography is
unfortunately a normal or normalized
habit
of uh men in this day and age i
understand that but there are limits i
mean your public twitter account can we
load up exactly how many accounts this
guy follows
can we load this up the number okay you
like poor and cool follow a porn star or
two cool watch pornhub jerk off to a
video or two look at the number of porn
accounts this guy's dad and him follow
this is this is a screenshot of all some
of some of the porn
actresses and only fans girls that ethan
klein's father interacts with which
means buys content from begs for videos
and sends support to on twitter
okay so
this guy this may all be secret [ __ ]
that he kept from his kid that he kept
from ethan but there was also i i could
purport that this guy taught him never
to be respectful to women didn't teach
him how to be a man and have you know
have a have a backbone there's something
going on with ethan yeah and there's
something going on with the dad am i
boring you oh i'm just like that's just
gross there's a second screenshot more
pages i mean you guys get the picture
you guys can get you need to be let me
tell you something you need good male
role models in your life to end up a
happy content person uh and health is is
step one to happiness in my opinion so
when i look up to my brother when we
looked up to our father when we looked
up to our kickboxing coach and the other
fighters and the athletes and people who
were around us who stayed away from
drugs you know
had healthy relationships with women
stayed in great shape and we ended up
how we were it's no surprise to
understand that this is why ethan klein
ended up where he is but ladies and
gentlemen what you have to understand is
this man has tens of thousands of people
watching him every time he live streams
and my advice to you again young men
these people do not respect you because
these are the people who want to
influence your opinions
they want to influence your opinions and
look at the and look at what they do
with their free time and and here's
another thing ethan if if you don't know
this
one of the major reasons
for erectile dysfunction and a lack of
function in the penis nowadays that
happens to men and it is a problem
that's getting much worse is the
consumption of pornography the over
consumption of pornography the
desensitization to sexual images the the
ridiculous amount of masturbation that
young men do and their testosterone so
bad for you right then they go to a real
girl and the real girl can't keep up
with this fake world so they're
desensitized and the real girl doesn't
turn them on anymore like what the [ __ ]
is that you're missing out get off that
[ __ ] and go enjoy the real stuff jesus
christ it's so crazy i am so glad and it
never my whole life it never really
occurred to me until this moment
watching ethan klein's father talk to
these ladies of the night because
they're not ladies that my father never
did a single thing that i can think of
not a single thing that i'm ashamed of
yeah he was
he was a jay he's a g he was a j worry
about the antidepressants my friend
ethan don't worry about you know um
about you know being overweight i'm
telling you your penis would work much
better if you didn't spend 16 hours a
day beating it while your wife doesn't
have sex with you can we get those
screenshots of his wife saying uh he's
saying he doesn't get any
actions feel bad bro no i'm advising him
i'm advising him so there's a screenshot
that i hope that you're gonna find right
now where he says i just got the first
bit of action that i've had in months
when my finger slipped through the
toilet paper and slipped up my butthole
on the toilet and his wife says you
shouldn't put this on twitter and he
says well
last time you slipped a finger up my
butthole was a long time ago one you
consider action getting your wife to
finger your bottle now cool right there
you're into what you're into i'm not
judging you but i'm telling you
they're getting divorced i'm i'm saying
it now read this though mark mark my
words if the divorce isn't already in
the works it's happening today i finally
slipped does this not look like a joke
to you though today i finally got some
action when my finger slipped through
the toilet paper all right yeah ethan i
said no twitter before breakfast okay
but when is the last time you poked my
butthole this tweet is kind of your
fault sorry about the racing twitter
there's a little bit of joking here i
feel like that's a complete joke but
what do i know active who inspires you
to have sex with her maybe be more of a
man for your wife so you can give her a
good time and sexually he's saying she's
not attractive that's not fair
because everybody's got their own thing
put down the porn and your life will be
happier and more fulfilled i swear to
god this is just good advice coming from
a man who has a very healthy
relationship with women who has
unlimited sexual access from women who
does not watch porn you you really need
to get your mind right bro no but these
people you know what it is for anybody
he's a sad man he takes pills he's just
a sad guy and he just sits on the
internet trying to tear down people he
wishes he was but like who would want to
as a woman i can say in my one personal
experience that i don't want to deal
with a sad dude like i'm not saying that
if if the man i love is going through a
sad time of course i'm going to be there
like i'm like as my son like separately
from all this [ __ ] like you can see
that i have compassion and i'm like hey
what do you what do we need to do here
like what's up right i'm a compassionate
person to my son my friends
if there's a man in my life but if your
general personality is your very
poor me it's gross of course he's not
getting any action from his wife oh and
and you know what it's not even his
fault because if that's his father i
mean this i've got a picture here of of
our dad if anyone didn't know but yeah
we had the best dad on the planet yeah
if you're watching this by the way no i
had the best dad on the planet
inside the matrix spread it around let's
pump the viewer number up forty thousand
people show everybody at the dollhouse
tonight what's wrong oh yeah our grandpa
built this thing behind us or my grandpa
not her grandpa yeah that's another
story we'll tell that in a minute
there's a story behind that little story
look at this guy look at this g so our
father was a fearsome predator and he
raised us to be fierce and predators but
if your father is just a cuckold porn
addict then i guess ethan's a result so
in a way he's kind of not responsible
he's a victim he's a victim but he needs
to be self-aware enough to understand
why he thinks the way he is and why he
hates us and and try and improve himself
because if he thing were to actually
wake up and say you know what i need to
become a better person i want to go to
the gym i want to train her et cetera
i'd encourage him i have nothing
personally ethan i would actually
encourage you like but yeah i mean your
father's porn addiction is kind of
embarrassing so that's going to become a
thing yeah follow us on rumble do the
thing join the discord blah blah blah
all right guys yeah do this do the [ __ ]
she said you're going to have to make a
course the universe a section of the
university i am i'm going to work on it
being a gentleman that would be that'd
be funny i actually have a good idea for
that already you'll get started i
actually have a base oh god the hiccups
i have a basis for it and a good
foundation which i've had an idea for
over a long time that i can actually use
for that for being a gentleman and and
making sure all the rules sure start
writing [ __ ] down you yourself are a
gentleman and you find a lady who
understands the same rules individually
all right guys indeed beautifully and do
whatever do all the [ __ ] yeah we use
that with every day
i do all right well it's fine
oh my gosh
[Music]